think about working from the outside in
towards this variable by doing the
opposite so first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to subtract 4 from both
sides okay so that equals negative 1 so
we've got log base 2 of X minus 1 equals
negative 1 now I want to get rid of this
log I'm trying to give this a variable
by itself so I'm going to do the inverse
of logs which is to exponentiate both
the left and the right sides using the
base two these are inverses they cancel
so now we're left with X minus 1 equals
1/2 because remember the negative
exponent takes the reciprocal I'm going
to add 1 to both sides we've got x
equals 1 and 1/2 that's our solution now
one thing you want to be careful of when
you do these log equations is that
sometimes you get an extraneous root
meaning that you want to take this
answer put it back into the original
problem make sure you're not taking the
log of 0 or a negative number because
remember the log graph it looks like
this right the domain is greater than 0
this argument here they call this the
argument has to be greater than 0 it has
to be positive so if you put this in
here and you get a negative cross it out
that's extremists that's a false answer
but in this case we're okay that's a
positive 1/2 let's go over here to this
problem next this one we've got log base
3 of X minus 1 equals log base 3 of 4 X
plus 2 these are both log base 3 this is
called the one-to-one property for logs
as long as these bases are the same you
have a log equals a log you can set the
arguments equal to each other so I'm
just going to cross those out X minus 1
equals 4x plus 2 I'm going to subtract X
that's 3x I'm going to subtract 2 that's
negative 3 I'm going to divide by 3 x
equals negative 1 but remember we have
to go back to the original problem if I
put negative 1 into you know these logs
here I'm getting a negative quantity
okay one might end up working out pause
and when I'm working out negative but if
there's one that's negative or zero you
can't take the log of 0 or negative
that's extraneous and that's what
happens here we have log of negative 2
that means this is an extraneous root
there's no solution to this problem
let's go back over to this one over here
now this one we've got two logs okay not
a log equipped a log like that one over
there what I'm going to do is I'm going
to use the properties of logs to combine
these into one log so what do you do
when you add you multiply two arguments
so let's do that we've got log base two
of X times X minus two which is x
squared minus two x equals three now my
goal is to get rid of this log so we can
get these variables by themself I'm
going to exponentiate both sides using
base 2 because this is log base two
exponential base two these are inverses
they cancel and now i've got x squared
minus 2x equals two cubed which is 8 I'm
going to get everything at one side and
set it equal to zero okay now we can
factor and set the factors to zero so
that factors as X minus four X plus 2
equals zero if I set each of these
factors equal to zero we get positive 4
and negative 2 but again we want to go
back and check if we put negative 2 in
here we're going to be taking the log of
a negative number so this is extraneous
I'm going to cross that one out if I put
4 in for is okay 4 minus 2 that's 2
that's positive that's okay
so it looks like we're just getting one
solution to this problem it's 4 so here
are some common examples you'll you'll
come across when you're solving log
equations one to one property or you
could try to get the log by itself and
then exponentiate both sides to get rid
of that log or you can even use the
properties of logs if you have more than
one log to combine them together so a
few different examples I'll see you in
the next video